this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e i have had so much
tea in my life i've been to china i've
lived in china in japan i've done tea
tours i drink a lot of tea and 10 years
plus a physical experimentation and
tracking has shown me many things chief
among them that gut health is critical
to just about everything and you'll see
where tea is going to tie into this it
affects immune function weight
management mental performance emotional
health you name it i've been drinking
fermented poo air tea specifically
pretty much every day for years now poor
tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome the
problem with good poo air is that it's
hard to source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why peaks fermented
poor tea crystals have become my daily
go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them through my friends dr peter
attia and kevin rose peak crystals are
cold extracted using only wild harvested
leaves from 250 year old tea trees i
often kick start my mornings with their
poor green tea their poor black tea and
i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the black specifically
is amazing it's very very it's like a a
delicious barnyard
very peaty if you like whiskey and stuff
like that they triple toxin screen all
of their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic mold contaminants
commonly found in tea there's also zero
prep or brewing required as the crystals
dissolve in seconds so you can just drop
it into your hot tea or i also make iced
tea and that saves a ton of time and
hassle
so peek is offering 15 off their
priorities for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer simply visit peaktee.com
tim that's p i q u e t e a dot com
forward slash tim this promotion is only
available to listeners of this podcast
that's peak t dot com forward slash tim
the discount is automatically applied
when you use that url you also have a 30
day satisfaction guarantee so your
purchase is risk free one more time
check it out peak t that's p i q u e t e
a dot com slash tim
this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason
the app and its simple four rule method
will change the way you think about your
money and help you gain total control so
you can plan for the things you need and
get the things you want without guilt or
stress to give you an idea on the cult
favorite side to date they know of at
least seven customers who have
customized their license plates to mark
the occasion of purchasing a new car in
cash and these fans do this by including
ynab you need a budget on their license
plates so people love this app you need
a budget has helped millions of people
transform their finances save their
marriages and live life on their own
terms i even asked pete adney who's been
on the podcast best known as mr money
mustache super popular episode what he
thought and he's a big fan of the
founder and what they're doing you need
a budget's simple four rule method will
actually teach you how to manage your
money you will learn a new way of
thinking new habits and new behaviors
that will help you get out of debt break
the paycheck to paycheck cycle and build
wealth faster the you need a budget team
is committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet if you want to learn they can
teach you on average new budgeters save
more than six hundred dollars by month
two and six thousand dollars in their
first year so try the app free for 34
days no credit card required at you need
a budget.com
tim spelled as you would expect in
proper english try you need a budget
free for 34 days no credit card required
at you
needabudget.com tim and just to explain
34 days that's because most people
reconcile at the end of the month or 38
period so having a couple of days of
cushion helps folks out so 34 days with
no credit card required at you need a
budget.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
if
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show my guest today is henry
shukman s-h-u-k-m-i-n
you can find him on instagram at
mountain cloud zen center henry teaches
mindfulness and awakening practices to a
wide range of students from all
traditions and walks of life henry is an
appointed teacher in the [ __ ] zen
lineage and is the guiding teacher of
mountain cloud zen center he was
introduced to me by my very close friend
kevin rose that is how this came to be
he has an m.a from cambridge and an
amulet from saint andrews and has
written several award-winning books of
poetry in fiction his essays have been
published in the new york times outside
and tricycle and his poems have been
published in the new republic guardian
sunday times that's in the uk and london
review of books henry has taught
meditation at google harvard business
school ubs eslin institute colorado
college united world college and many
other venues he's written of his own
journey in his latest book one blade of
grass subtitle finding the old road of
the heart a zen memoir and that book was
gifted to me by the aforementioned kevin
rose affectionately known as kevkev on
this podcast very often the website is
mountaincloud.org you can find
both henry and mountain cloud zen center
on instagram at mountain cloud zen
center facebook facebook.com
mtn cloudzen and you can find henry on
linkedin linkedin.com
i n slash henry hyphen shookman
s-h-u-k-m-a-n henry welcome to the show
well thanks so much for having me you're
truly honored and humbled to be with you
i'm excited to dig in and as i mentioned
before we start recording i think we
will run out of time before we run out
of material but we must start somewhere
so i wanted to start in perhaps an odd
place and
that is
to go into mythology for a moment and
specifically to talk about if i'm
getting the pronunciation right typhon
the mythological beast who lived under
the volcano aetna and i've read that at
one point you felt like this
mythological beast
and i would love for you to explain why
that is the case okay well that's going
right back to early years
great place to start actually basically
i had raging
severe
eczema
that's a skin affliction many people
might know of it and think of it as just
a rash or something now and then but it
can be quite severe and i had it
chronically for i guess like more or
less the first it's hard to say two to
three decades of my life starting from
the age of six months
and
when i was a kid i was often in hospital
for stretches and stuff it was it was at
that sort of level
and typhon i remember hearing about him
in class at school you know into greek
mythology
lived under mount etna the volcano
and
he kind of could survive the sulfurous
raging heat down there
and i
lived
quite a lot of my early life in
a kind of sulfurous raging heat that
came out through my skin
and i don't want to over dramatize it
but from living it from the inside
it was very difficult it was like being
slowly on fire or something eczema is
when it's bad it itches
to an unimaginable degree
it's really quite debilitating and
the doctors in the uk in the 1970s when
i was growing up they didn't really have
a lot of great sort of tools they had
one tool that was really effective which
was heavy steroids but they didn't like
to use them the thing that really made
the big difference for me was actually
meditation you know i took it up in my
early mid-20s
and it made a dramatic difference quite
quickly it wasn't that i was over it
forever but things really shifted once i
started meditating and i'm not
suggesting that all eczema sufferers
will find the same thing because there's
a complicated
multi-faceted
affliction
and there aren't clear-cut
factors actually it really is rather
tricky i think for a lot of people to
to handle it
but for me that piece of
essentially
getting a method
for
calming the nervous system
which i had not realized needed calming
by the way
the thing is again if you grow up with
this kind of thing i think anybody with
a chronic
ailment of some kind knows what this is
like that
i mean i suppose it depends when you
first get it but especially for kids you
just think this is normal
you don't know that there's something
dysfunctional going on it's just this is
how the world is
in my case i started to
actually taste
a different kind of way of being alive
it was a really big deal it was it was
wondrous to me
i was just going to hop in to also paint
a picture for folks because
you had this itching weeping bleeding
and so forth
and the severity of it is remarkable and
when i've read it at least that is
having a district nurse coming to you
daily laying you on a towel bathing you
an antiseptic solution wrapping you in
coal tar bandages
and so on i mean this was a
non-trivial
condition and
when you say
that you
weren't even aware the nervous system
needed calming do you think the eczema
was in response to something that was a
psychosomatic and not in a
not in a way that diminishes it but
literally psycho hyphen somatic response
to
something that you can identify do you
have any
thoughts on what generated that
experience
well yes i do actually i think i mean of
course in a certain sense this is kind
of
private personal mythology of another
kind but what i know happened was that
when i was six months old
my parents were
living for a semester in helsinki and
actually both my parents were professors
both in russian studies
and they had a
my dad actually i think had a fellowship
in helsinki university for for a
semester and we all went over there that
was my older brother
and myself just six months old
mom and dad
and
this may sound a little fanciful but
it's actually real and true but because
this was actually back in the 1960s
when the cold war was really you know
hot it's really happening
at that time basically anybody
who could speak russian in britain was
likely to be
in some way or other approached and used
by
the intelligence
community
and that was true of my mum and my dad
they were both
recruited early on actually while they
were studying russian still
to
mi5 or mi6
and they didn't do anything you know
massively sort of it wasn't kind of
james bond stuff you know it was just
like could you tell us about this
scientist who's just been sent to the
gulag or can you read this report and
occasionally they'd get
involved in
little minor operations or whatever
this all came to light much later by the
way
after the 50 years of the official
secrets act had expired when a lot came
to light about
things that have been going on in the
world of espionage
in the uk
with the soviet union but while they
were in helsinki
my dad was
requested that he would go to leningrad
which is just
not so far away across the gulf of
finland
and my mum
i don't know the exact circumstances but
for whatever reason she went to
and that was how she weaned me
so she left this baby that had been
seemingly well
went to russia for whatever they were
doing there came back
a week later or ten days later or five
days later i've heard different versions
of the story and when they got back i
was covered in eczema
and so
i imagine that i went through something
pretty difficult
while my mother was suddenly gone and at
the same time was weaned of the breast
and put on
formula
and by probably somebody i didn't know
and
it must have been very very difficult
for me
i think in some way that
if i can call it trauma which i guess i
can
that trauma
has been
very very important for my whole life
actually and even for
the
path to and beyond awakening
i'm very interested these days and how
trauma and awakening relate to each
other i think i'm not the only one
people are starting to look into that
there's something about
deep wounding
that can be a pathway
to deep deep love it's a very beautiful
thing when
the wound becomes the doorway
i think there's always that potential
with a wound but so much of the time
we tend to
accrete protection over a wound and sort
of
stay away from a wound and you know
avoid it and live as if it weren't there
so unpicking the defenses
and actually
finding
some kind of way usually it needs
support actually some sort of supported
way to go into our wounds and what we
find there in the place that we're most
terrified of
can be just
of course pain but also great great love
honestly in certain ways i'm jumping
crazily ahead tim in terms of a
trajectory but but to me there's
something just amazing at how
deep deep wound and deep deep awakening
they've got things in common
that i find mind-blowing and really
really beautiful and i think there's a
blessing in going into our wounds and
maybe to a lot of people this sounds
crazy but i really think
often the thing that we fear most the
thing that seems most what we don't want
can turn out to be
the
great opening for us
what type of meditation did you start
with what was your first entree to
meditation which helped you to calm your
nervous system and begin to resolve
the eczema
that was tm transcendental meditation in
the sort of late 80s by then in london
that was the most sort of conspicuous
game in town if you wanted to meditate
yeah yeah
they still had this kind of cachet in
england because the beatles had done it
for sure
they went out to rishikesh or whatever
it was and hung out with maharishi
mahesh
yogi
and so there was this sort of
endorsement that somehow
tm
wasn't sort of too weird
it's kind of weird but not so weird and
actually the
tagline was
life tool for the busy
that's great i've never heard
[Laughter]
so they kind of
undercut any worry that you might be
sort of checking out from life and going
into some weird cult this was going to
help your career that's how all the best
calls get you
[Laughter]
i also i still practice tm at points so
i'm not
casting aspersions i'm mostly just
poking fun
let me come back to a term you used
because i want to keep track of
definitions for people who are new to
all of what we're talking about and i'm
going to be new to a lot of what we're
talking about you mentioned
the term awakening what does that mean
here how should we define it for people
listening
i could give a really dry definition or
i could give an account or i could do
both let's do both
in whichever order you like
okay let's do dry first i think this
will be quite short the sort of working
definition for me and i think many
others in this field would be to awaken
is to see that
the sense of self that the me that i
have taken myself to be for as long as i
can remember
has been a kind of genie it's been a
kind of mirage that constructed itself
and then believed in itself now this is
not in any way to sort of diminish
okay i want to get to this later that
you know really the whole world of sort
of healing the self is dear to my heart
and very very important i don't go along
with people who just say to trash the
self say forget it self is just a
delusion you hear that in spiritual
circles self is just a delusion and it
may sound like i'm saying that right now
in one level it is and in another level
we must take it seriously that's how i
take it so to awaken is actually to see
that the sense of self the sense of me
has not been what i've taken it to be
all along
instead
it can actually be seen through
so that we realize it's never been here
the way we've thought
from the start it's never really been
here quite the way we took it to be
that's one side awaken the other crucial
component here is that when that happens
when we see through the sense of me as a
separate being all the rest of the world
is out there i'm in here
when that is gone we discover
that we belong in an utterly wonderful
way
to and with everything
we find that there is actually another
level of our experience and it's right
here now it's not some
weird other state we go to it's actually
right intrinsic to our ordinary
experience it's just that we don't see
it we rarely see it most of us
seldom see it but it's actually never
hidden it's just that we're totally
conditioned away from seeing it it
sounds very weird and it is very unusual
in the sense we don't normally
experience things like this but it's
actually present right now and always
there's another dimension another aspect
another face
of our experience of this very moment in
which
we are totally
part of everything and so that's the
flip side so an awakening is sort of one
thing vanishes that sense of self
and another thing appears which is what
that sense of self was occluding in some
sense which is that there's this
unbelievable
wondrous participation that we have we
are part of everything even to say we're
part of everything is it's not quite
getting it we discover in a moment
awakening we are all
is that enough for now do you want to
respond to that nina well i'd like to
encourage you to perhaps illustrate it
with a story and
the question perhaps that i could ask in
the meanwhile is
is it fair to say that the experience of
awakening or
waking up
of course you you've done quite a lot
with sam harris on the waking up app
and with sam
who is also a close friend
and
is
this experience of awakening
a
repeatable or repeated phenomena in
other words you hear the term which i've
never really
gravitated towards enlightenment gets
used in different spiritual traditions
or different practices and it seems kind
of like a zero to one one time event and
lickety-split there you are even though
you still have to carry water and
file your taxes and so on yeah typically
but
is this experience of awakening
something that
in practice recurs with some regularity
here's a metaphor that a great 20th
century scene master called yamada koton
used
he said it's like this imagine that
we've been living in a room made of
opaque glass
in a moment of awakening
a hole is suddenly poked or drilled or
smashed through part of one of those the
walls of the room
and we see
kind of a bright world outside
the box of glass of opaque glass that
we've been dark glass that we've been
living in suddenly we see oh my god
there's a world out there that's really
so different
so that's one
instant of awakening that would be
one way that awakening can be defined is
a sudden moment of revelation can i tell
a little story now that would this be
appropriate to say what that's like
you're very you're very british my
friend yes it would be entirely
appropriate please continue i love it i
love it i wish i had your accent my god
people would think give me a bonus 20 iq
points i would love that but please
please continue yes
we got two hours here so the iq level
will tank i'm sure as we go
here's a story when i was 19 i'd
actually gone away from the uk on a to
work abroad you know during my gap year
after school
i went to argentina and then i
backpacked through bolivia with a friend
and while i was doing that i wrote my
first book actually and then in peru and
towards the end of the journey
having written this book and you know 19
i'd always wanted to be a writer a poet
i was so happy i'd actually finished
this whole book and i'd worked and
earned some money and seen the world and
i've been in a totally different
universe from
the rainy academic library riddled world
i'd grown up in at books
books and rain basically that was oxford
you know i mean very beautiful you know
books and rain and old stone walls i
mean it was marvelous and poetic and
lovely and all the rest of it to go to
bolivia 13 000 foot plateau
with
people living just utterly different
kinds of lives you know just so
different
and to be able to travel this was again
back in the 80s traveling in the backs
of trucks everywhere just
trundling through this immense landscape
and this ultra clear air and sky and
with my best friend who is a
photographer and i'm writing and he's
taking photographs and we're going to
make a book together and actually we did
a few years later it came out
it was the opposite of the life i'd
known so constricted and on that journey
actually before going i had managed to
persuade my doctor to actually give me a
tube of steroid cream because i didn't
want to be 5 000 miles away with a
raging eczema flare-up he gave me that
and i hardly ever used it somehow in the
new climate in a
totally different dietary system
whatever i don't know what and this
feeling of being free and
out from under a heavy cloud and
not having realized i've been living
under such a heavy cloud all those years
somehow
that was the first taste actually for me
that eczema might clear up so i'm just
painting the picture a little bit eczema
gone my skin was normal it was it was
can you imagine after all those years to
see that i had this beautiful brownish
sort of part jewish sephardic a bit
brown beautiful skin smooth and
and not a blemish on it not an itch and
not a not a hurt it was amazing to be
healed like that and i was writing this
book and there was a certain point
towards the end of the trip where i
holed up in a little hostel in a room
50 cents a night or something and just
drank coca-cola
pints of coffee smoked winston
cigarettes and rode about 80 pages of
this book what was the book about it was
about this journey
this very journey you know it was called
sons of the moon and it was very
exciting you know it got published in
london and new york and i was still
pretty young and it was very thrilling
having done the book having healed the
skin towards the end of the trip i was
alone on a beach on the pacific ocean
late one afternoon
and the beach was deserted
and i was just watching this desert
coast up there
i was going to say featureless that's
not quite right but just kind of bare
barren stark
coastline
and there's this sun
getting close to the horizon
nobody around
a little boat anchored offshore
and i'm just gazing
at the path of light
that the sun
was laying on the water it was probably
only like a hand's width above the
horizon or something like that that
beautiful scintillating path of light
that leads out to the horizon
that you get on the ocean and i noticed
that this boat
had disappeared i knew it was there but
it disappeared and then suddenly i saw
it it was just a silhouette inside the
path of light and it was there as a sort
of black silhouette and then it
disappeared again in the sparkling light
and it just struck me as extraordinarily
beautiful i don't know why but that
image of a boat being there and then not
being there and being there again kind
of like a stain on the retina when
you've looked at such a bright light
that was what it was like to me sort of
in reverse it came it went it came it
went
it was
overwhelmingly beautiful i don't know
what more to say than that but
as this sense of its great beauty welled
up in me and filled my heart actually
with a
great sense of love
suddenly
something
utterly
unprecedented for me unexpected unknown
weird happened to me which was that
the scene i was looking at
wasn't outside me
and i wasn't outside it
we became one
it's a glib way to put it actually when
i say it now we became one it doesn't
convey what it was really like it was
utter beauty it was like being swallowed
up by beauty and becoming
home coming home in a way that
i didn't know i hadn't been home if you
know what i mean anyway i'll just finish
the experience it was like becoming part
of the world
instead of being an isolated
entity
stalking the earth upright on the earth
separate from it moving through it as a
sort of bubble almost like it's got this
membrane around it called skin
and that skin
separates the entity
from the world
instead
it's like the skin was gone the
separation was gone there was just one
reality
one kind of dream one kind of movie
and
that's what i was
and
it was like finding i belonged to a
degree
that was inconceivable because i didn't
just belong i was actually part
of the very sort of fabric
of everything that's what happened and
in the midst of that
i don't know if i'm going too fast too
deep too weird but i'll just
that should be the tagline of my podcast
[Laughter]
please continue
okay
basically in the midst of it there was a
sort of moment also where it was mind
blown because
all space had disappeared there was no
distance anywhere it was like
i felt like my nose was pressing against
the end of time
my nose was touching the furthest
reaches of the universe because it was
all just here it was one reality without
space without time it was just
utterly mind-blowing i'm describing a
moment of awakening so
how long did it last i don't really know
but not very long somewhere between five
seconds and five minutes i'm guessing
then there was kind of like
knowing i was a human being on a beach
again
taking a step and how extraordinary it
was just to take a step how marvelous to
be able to do such a thing as sort of be
a body and take a step everything seemed
sort of new it was just
it was like a new world and it was so so
beautiful my heart was just
it felt like a flame
was burning in my heart
i know it sounds a little bit like the
old accent of trouble but actually it
was a beautiful beautiful thing it's
just a flame of love burning in my heart
i knew that i had found
the answer
but i hadn't even been asking a question
i'd had no interest at all
in spirituality
definitely not religion i was
very atheist or just totally atheist i
was
kind of still am actually but that's
another matter i had no
interest in
whatever that experience might have been
it wasn't in my
world view at all
and i think because i had no
preconceptions at all about
whatever that kind of experience might
have been none at all i was able to just
go with it like a complete
azure new i just totally naive i i just
was what's this
whoa and what's this as it sort of got
deeper and weirder i just
went with it and it was so beautiful
that i sort of trusted it
and then
kind of in a sense i was back
in a known world
it was also so different because it was
just so
so so beautiful and
it was like everything was
feather light and paper thin
as one of my teachers likes to say i
weighed nothing i was sort of
see-through and the world was
see-through i mean it existed it would
look like it normally did but it had
become weightless and so beautiful and
so that was a moment of awakening but
the real moment itself
was only short but there's long long
after glow
that lasted weeks
and my heart was so alive and i you know
as i sort of walking through streets of
town seeing kids on the street i just
wanted to help wherever i could and i
felt
human suffering in a new way a different
way and yeah like i said i i felt that i
had found
the answer to life which i hadn't been
looking for
and wasn't interested in
but but now it was like i knew i could
die and my life had been fulfilled it
wouldn't matter what else happened to me
so if i could pause for a moment i have
a number of questions and i'm going to
act as a stand-in for some of the
audience here
with one yeah please
were you entirely sober for that
experience or was it enhanced in any way
stone cold sober okay i've never had
anything stronger than sort of a beer
virtually
you have not
then i hadn't okay all right
i have some follow-up questions yeah i
mean a few years later actually i
dropped acid
and it was
meaningless
it was so shallow compared to
it it didn't come close to what i'd
experienced yeah interesting all right
we'll have more follow-ups
on that theme but
the next question is in retrospect now
is someone who
studies
i suppose the phenomenon of this
experience
of awakening this type of awakening
what do you think were the ingredients
in
that
encapsulated period of time that led to
that
spontaneous
actualization or realization
of feeling
as you did
i've wondered that myself at times i
could say
the most immediate probably was the fact
that i was really closely studying what
i was looking at and asking questions as
a writer you mean yeah but i mean i had
been doing that as a writer exactly but
actually in the very moment
i was staring at this phenomenon
of the very bright light on the water
this boat sort of appearing and
disappearing in the light i was asking
myself
i know the physics of this basically
there's water which is transparent
there's air which is transparent there's
the surface where these two things are
meeting
and there's light landing on that
surface
that's what's going on
why does it look the way it looks was
kind of my question
because the surface i noticed that it
was so dazzlingly bright
but it was really composed of these
bright scales that were shifting over
the surface and
where a scale was it was super bright
but when the scale slid off it was
actually super dark
so it was this mix of black and white
and i was just looking at it very
closely and i think one ingredient
was
scrutiny i was really studying what i
was looking at and this was as you
mentioned it was on the back of
several months of considering
to the best of my ability deeply what i
was seeing as i've been traveling
and you know also when working because
it was also novel so that was another
factor
i suspect also this is maybe a little
bit weirder but the eczema
years of eczema
of having to somehow
sit with or lie with or be with
quite intense discomfort
that wasn't going to go away
i suspected it had done something to my
consciousness as a kind of training of
some kind i mean it wasn't one i'd wish
on anybody and i certainly didn't
appreciate it
for this but i think it probably
had somehow taught me
very very unwillingly
some kind of tolerance
and
i suspect that i could only find that
tolerance
when i sort of shifted gear in my mind
in some way there were certain times
when that was quite vivid there were
times with the eczema
especially sort of lying in bed itching
at night when i would really go into a
different state of mind that was
very alert very present very attentive
and blissful and peaceful and i'd feel
like i was in a kind of
cocoon
and i could have stayed there forever
was there something you did
consciously was there a method to
achieving that state or did it just
manifest itself unexpectedly
unfortunately it was the latter i wished
i could i remember wanting to learn how
to make it happen and i didn't know how
to make it happen it would just randomly
happen i kind of learned
how to let it prolong itself which was
i found there was a way of
being with it
without
holding on to it if i could put it like
that i noticed that if i wanted it to
stay
it would go away but i could just be
with it
and not
wish it would stay and it would stay
that was the only level of proficiency
so to speak i got with it but i couldn't
make it happen
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by all
form from the creators of helix sleep
all form makes premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped right to your
door at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores so i'm sitting in my
living room right now and it's entirely
all form furniture i've got two chairs
i've got an ottoman and i have an l
sectional couch so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allform.com
tim all forms offering 20 off all orders
to you my dear listeners at allforum.com
tim that's all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m
dot com slash tim
i started getting interested in this
form of practice called janna practice
this is really getting into the weeds so
i won't take long in it some people
might have heard of this
many probably won't it's a particular
form of practice from early buddhism
known as diana or janna how do you say
actually funny
j h a n a that's the party and diana in
sanskrit is d-h-y-a-n-a
and actually that is the word that
became
chana in chinese or chan which then
became zen in japanese so zen is
connected in some way to this kind of
practice but the janna practice is this
regarded as quite esoteric and sort of
tricky difficult sort of advanced
practice
the first time i got trained to do it
there's eight different states by the
way i just went into the first one
fairly easily i couldn't believe it it
was exactly that state i'd been in as a
kid
i don't know what the
i don't know how this actually all fits
together but i had been doing something
in the midst of eczema
that had some kind of correlation very
vaguely or
in a sort of abstruse connection with
meditation
i had somehow and i don't know whether
could it be that that in some way
precipitated that experience i don't
know i don't really know
could it be that years of
living with great discomfort and somehow
having to find ways to just endure it or
not and just sort of be tormented by it
could that have been some kind of
preparation or was it simply that
having lived like that a long time and
suddenly being well
it was sort of mind-blowing to be well
and in this moment of
solitude
in the midst of the sort of mighty
forces of the ocean the sun the sky
the sand and alone
i remember actually before it happened i
thought i could be any man in any
century because all there was was the
sea
this boat there was a kind of timeless
type of boat shape it wasn't some modern
speed boat or cruiser i think it was
just a simple boat could have been
the year 1200 and i had pair of shorts
on i could have been
any century any person and i perhaps in
that moment there was a bit of a loss of
identity that
paved the way maybe
what happened after that in the
let's say the subsequent 12 months what
was your was there anything notable that
happened after that
oh my god yeah totally because about i
had a sort of blessed few weeks
transfigured world after it
and then i went home my parents had
split up when i was young
and i'd had a very sort of
difficult relationship with my dad
feeling very sort of abandoned and
just heartbroken at his leaving then
there was a difficult remarriage it was
very complicated
emotional
domestic arrangement that we all had to
live in
from when i was about seven onwards
and it had never been resolved it had
never really been spoken about it was
this awful english middle class sort of
reticence to talk about feelings and
yeah that we were all
seized by possessed by and us kids my
brother and sister and i you know we
were
caught in this very difficult parental
tangle
but somehow
the absence of speaking about it
led to
any sort of
understanding that this was a difficult
situation again it's the sort of kid
thing where i don't know that this isn't
normal this is the way the world is i've
got to learn to live with it it's me
that's at fault if i don't like it kind
of thing
that i think many children i assume
would
feel that way
so i
have had this
awakening i'm wide open my heart is just
so full
of love and
of wonder and i come home
and i walk through the door of my dad's
house
within half an hour
i had a kind of breakdown i felt
overwhelmed by
the unhappiness of my childhood
in a way that i'd never actually felted
during my childhood i'd had defenses
against it
and when i came home i had no defenses i
was wide open
all the unhappiness that i actually
experienced during it just kind of
tumbled
on top of me and i kind of collapsed i
i went into a
a very sort of closed down and miserable
state of mind actually for several years
i kind of got through it i
somehow sort of limped along
very unhappily with the help of
alcohol and
not very good hash
and
[Laughter]
not even good hash
junior varsity hash on top of it all
right
books are great and bad hash
yes
exactly
and some good friends i mean i although
even my friendships have been sort of i
mean they're very good friends but
somehow i was so broken that i couldn't
even really connect with my old friends
it was a miserable time it was
transcendental meditation that
helped me out all of it i'm not sure
whether that's enough on that misery
well well let's
i mean i'm a
connoisseur of
depressive episodes and anxiety and so
forth but
let me ask you on that
topic
how often would you say
[Music]
do
what you would consider awakenings
overlap with what
others might call a psychotic episode
or are they easily distinguished or
would a psychiatrist with a dsm desk
reference categorize it as
a psychotic episode part of the reason i
ask is that i've seen people in
multiple practices sometimes
breath work could be kundalini could be
any number of things
extended
silent retreats
extended fasts i've seen people have
what some or what they might consider
breakthroughs i've observed people
certainly you see this with psychedelics
as well who have had
what many would consider breakdowns and
to become untethered for some period of
time
how do you think about distinguishing
those if you do
first of all
i'm not well versed in kundalini
and i know that there are powerful
experiences that happen in that
i've seen somebody go through something
like that during a retreat i was part of
and it was much more about energy
and not so much about discovery
i would want to be quite careful in our
taxonomy
and not just put them all under one
heading awakening experiences there are
different kinds of breakthrough
experiences actually there are different
kinds of awakening experiences even
within zen
but fundamentally i don't think they
overlap the way that it could be highly
problematic and even
in a sense could
get muddled up with psychosis
is really more if the context isn't a
very supportive one but you know the
fundamental thing discovered in real
awakening
is that we're part of everything and
that's a blessed most blessed thing to
discover
and
yeah it can be very destabilizing for me
it wasn't destabilizing what happened
was i went home and had to face the
trauma i'd never faced right because i
was now open enough to in the hands if
i'd had a great therapist at the time it
would have been a golden opportunity
because i was open and last my defenses
were gone
i don't actually think that the misery
that followed was because of the
awakening i think it was because i had
all this unprocessed misery
that i had never known how to let myself
feel and suddenly in that context i had
no choice but to feel it
and actually in a way it took years but
i've come to see that that experience of
the breakdown so to speak was
as important in its way
as the awakening because
my whole thing now
is a path of awakening and healing both
and
i think one of the hazards of modern
western embrace of eastern spirituality
which has been fantastic i mean how
amazing that we're even sitting here
having a conversation about something
called awakening and we kind of have
enough common ground to have a sense of
what that might be that it's in the
zeitgeist now it's given me a lot of
credit
but please continue
one of the hazards have been this sort
of over enthusiasm about enlightenment
and awakening that can leave behind the
the healing side that has to go on as
well and on the other hand there's
we had all this deep freudian therapy
and all kinds of therapy now it's
fantastic that we do
but it doesn't really know about
awakening and often is very suspicious
of it things you know freud thought it
was sort of oceanic and infantile
regression many therapists when they
write about enlightenment awakening they
try to bring it into their world view
and it doesn't fit in their world view
because it's a totally different
register of experience so i know my
whole thing now is like let's get clear
there are these different dimensions of
experience that human beings can go
through and they're not all on the same
sort of level they're all in our heart
they're all sort of
what we're capable of what we can
experience
they sort of shouldn't tread on each
other's toes it's kind of how i feel
about it now for example deep profound
non-dual awakening is a fantastic thing
somatic release of trauma through deep
somatics everything that's a fantastic
thing working with i don't know too much
about it i've done actually we can get
onto it i've done ayahuasca which was
you know so i've got a little bit of a
sense of plant medicine for healing
that's fantastic and there's different
levels of experience there's different
levels of healing i would say awakening
is a kind of most profound healing but
it's not on the same level as the trauma
that i needed to heal
from my childhood it was a more
universal kind of discovery of what a
human being is any human being what
human consciousness what human awareness
is it was a discovery about that about
what this life is that
it's not really on the same level as the
psychological healing i also needed it
happened to open that up
and it took me a few years to find ways
to
do the healing or begin
the long healing that was needed on that
level
but on the level of awakening i was
still
somehow
fully healed in the awakening experience
this is one of the weird things about it
is that
god i'm still worried that i'm going off
the deep end well let me let me yeah
well deep end we're just getting warmed
up we're still in the kiddie pool we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna go to some
very strange places so before we do
i i want to mention a few things and to
maybe provide a bit of a teaser for
folks also so there there's certain
terms that i still have an aversion to
rightly or wrongly like enlightenment
awakening i can get on board with
for a number of reasons so we won't
dwell on that right now but i do find
it could be helpful to add a bit of
color
in a few areas for folks who are
listening so
and and hopefully i'm not stealing
thunder here i just want to mention a
few things and then if i could ask one
very crass question which is a total
non-sequitur but i have to ask because
i'm too curious and i have to scratch
that itch so the first thing i want to
mention to folks is that
and
we can certainly talk more about this
but part of the reason
that your teaching
and lineage appeals to me and i've
spoken to kevin about this is because
awakening does not equal checking out
right you're not
you're not requiring the people join a
monastic order of ascetics and
give up all
engagement with the world and we'll
probably come back to this but one of
your if not your primary teacher we can
talk about this but yamada roshi is ceo
of a company of 2000 employees who wrote
the biggest check
in its history or maybe we can get more
contacts there while leading mitsubishi
securities and so for people who don't
know mitsubishi is like one of the key
to like one of the
gigantic
monster conglomerates in japan it's it's
hard to overstate how big a deal that is
he also continues the zones in training
and trains around 75 zen teachers
worldwide right so you can be
of this world while still
developing
these
tools or utilizing these tools in the
toolkit so that's i just wanted to
underscore that just so it doesn't seem
as though we're kind of frolicking in a
bath of esoteric sciences that don't
apply to people who still want to engage
with the world
i also want to paint a picture because
there's no way we're going to get to it
all but i want to paint a picture of
your bizarre
and incredible life story i want to give
a couple of samples so
as a young man you worked as a
professional trump bonus playing in
calypso and salsa bands all over the
place hitchhiked across the sahara as a
young man and i don't think we're gonna
get to the egyptian doctor i wanted to
ask you about that but we might not have
time
this is the part where i have a crass
question it might be because i don't
speak the queen's english but you roam
the countryside as young teens sleeping
out and we're mentored by an old school
[ __ ] that is the term i'm i'm very
interested in trying to live like an
ancient chinese chan poet
there are a lot of loose ends here but
i found old-school [ __ ] to be very
intriguing
could you just explain that portion of
everything i just threw out there please
oh my god well the term [ __ ] in the uk
it used to refer to these guys who just
wondered the highways and byways ah okay
got it it wasn't
out of work geisha okay got it yeah
exactly
these days they talk about the [ __ ]
stamp i don't know if it's a tattoo you
know
do you know that term i'm familiar with
i don't know much about enlightenment
but i do know the term [ __ ] step
it shows you where where we're gonna
have to meet in the middle
so yeah i had this friend i mean he was
he would come to our valley every summer
and put up in this ruined mill and he
kind of mentored me and a couple of
friends of mine how to live on the land
when we were 14 15 we got into that we
were would be young poets
and we knew these those chinese poets we
were into them they were they were
seventh eighth century
lipo
great great poets who did a lot of
wondering at least we got that
impression they would wander around the
gorges and
write poems and drink rice wine
and they were actually a great
inspiration for the beats as well you
know kerouac and ginsburg and so on gary
snyder they got into these posts they
gone into zen because those poets used
to do zen as well they would meditate
they would go to monasteries go to
hermitage yeah salinger
allensburg
right right sanitary used a coan in one
of his
books as an epigraph let me
zoom out for a minute and i want to hear
the story of how you got to zen and
you noted for instance that at one point
tm was all the rage the sort of hippest
game in town
it was a life
life tool for busy people
and they had they had a great sort of
celebrity outreach program right they
have the beatles
even today of course they've got you
know jerry seinfeld hugh jackman they
have many many celebrities engaged
who
practiced tm and there was a period of
time where that was all the rage and
then you have sort of this yogananda
period right steve jobs etc
was zen just sort of the zeitgeist for a
period of time and you became engaged
while it was sort of in the slipstream
of the zeitgeist so i'd like to hear
that story and in the process of telling
that story i would love for you to
best you can define
what characterizes the practice of zen
buddhism because
i have found it very confusing and part
of me thinks that's kind of the point
and i'll give you an example i was at a
retreat
at spirit rock in northern california
this is many years ago and i heard a
story from one of the teachers
and she described how she was having a
lot of trouble figuring out certain
aspects of zen buddhism and at one point
she was having breakfast with her
teacher and they were eating in silence
and then suddenly he shouted
you know it's not logical okay
and
so there was this and that was it was a
teaching moment for her and she took a
lot from that and when i sort of think
of koans and these various things it
seems like almost the point is to
bludgeon
your
rational mind into submission so that
you can experience reality past the
constructs of concepts and labels and so
on but that's my best guess honestly i
don't know what zen buddhism or zen
practice is so that is a huge mouthful i
just kind of foie brought a lot of word
salad into the microphone
but the story of how you found zen and
then what in fact zen is would be very
helpful the story of how i found zen is
i was doing another book that my
publisher that commissioned me to write
it was about new mexico it was about the
english writer d.h lawrence in new
mexico and i was 28 at the time and
while i was out here i
made friends with a dear friend of mine
natalie goldberg who's a writer who
writes
zen-based writing writing down the bones
is that right exactly it's a great book
yeah great book yeah yeah
and natalie and i we hit it off actually
she rented me a room in her house in
santa fe and
it was great on trader to living out
here that she offered me but along the
way one evening she was reading me a bit
of this great
famous zen writer teacher poet dogen
from 13th century japan
she was reading a bit of dogen
i didn't understand a word of it it was
just kind of weird nonsense about
mountains walking i just sort of didn't
even want to think about it i just
i couldn't understand it wasn't
interested
conversation moved on
and i found myself thinking about it and
the next day i was still thinking about
it the day after i was still thinking
about it and then i remember vividly i
was washing a mug up at the sink in her
kitchen
and i suddenly got this thought
maybe
dogan was speaking from what i had
experienced on that beach years ago
nine years earlier i gotta say ever
since that beach moment had happened one
of the things that made me so miserable
one of the ways i made myself very
miserable was by thinking but oh my god
i discovered this freedom this beauty
this wonder this love this total
fulfillment and look at me now depressed
and miserable and anxious and eczema has
come back actually by the way and
why haven't i managed to
keep hold of that incredible discovery
why haven't i managed to live from it
why haven't i taken a step to sort of
somehow revisiting it whatever the hell
it had been
and so
by this point i'd been doing my tm for
four or five years absolutely
religiously every day twice a day you
know
it was my lifeline
and it had really been helping it hadn't
really occurred to me that the
meditation thing i was doing with them
could have anything to do with that
moment on the beach it just hadn't
occurred to me but suddenly i hear this
bit of dogen that makes no sense
somehow it came to me from the
perspective of that moment
it would make sense i can't exactly
explain how i knew it i just knew it and
i said to natalie what's this zen all
about
you know i want to know more and she
said well
you don't really know about zen you just
do it
and i said well i want well i want to do
it.
there and then she phoned up a friend of
hers who was a zem practitioner in town
and
and the next day i went and met with him
and he taught me how to do zazen or zen
meditation
which was
beautifully
simple
we sat in there there's this beautiful
little zendo that's still here in santa
fe beautiful little zender
sitting on a black cushion on a black
mat
facing the wall
and all you do is breathe
maybe in a way that's part of the
challenge there's not a lot to it with
tm you had this mantra that you you use
and it's sort of it's a lifeline through
the practice and you kind of know you've
got some sense that this mantra is doing
you some good kind of thing but with zen
you just sit there in a posture that is
a little bit more prescribed and sort of
set up but actually it's very
the posture's got a beautiful
intrinsic
peaceful
liveliness in it
that i felt the first time this guy set
me up in it i feel
huh
this feels
weirdly good
somehow an aliveness
a different quality of awareness
just switched on
and i felt
like i was right in that room
in a more vivid way
than normal
and then all i had to do was watch the
breath
and count it in sets of 10.
so
simple
and
it's not like i had some marvelous
enlightenment experience right then but
i did have a sense
in that first sit
that this was a way
of contacting life
this was a way of being
alive
that brought you in intimate contact
with being
alive and that wasn't something i'd ever
felt in tm i'd felt many other marvelous
things
but not
this is a sort of
if you want to know what life is
this can help you
that was the feeling i got from zen can
you remind me of how long that first
session was
it wasn't long it might have been 15 or
20 minutes i can't remember but it was
enough
what characterized it that led you
to feel the way you did about it
why did you feel that way
i think there may be something in the
posture
i think there may have been something in
the way this guy taught it to me he was
a very experienced practitioner
it could be honestly the fact that i'd
done four years or five years of
meditation by then so i was more
open and ripe for another practice than
i might otherwise have been
i think there was
probably something of a setup from what
had happened with this
piece of dogen
that i'd been fascinated by because that
had reawakened
my curiosity about the beach
that beach experience what the hell
happened then
might this be a way
to revisit that might there even be a
way
not just to revisit it but to go through
it and beyond it might there be a land
a world of life
beyond that experience so it wasn't just
the flash in the pan and it sort of
closes and you're done with it and you
have to
limp along in your ordinary life may i
just pivot to the coan question because
actually it was a little bit later that
i found my first
zen teacher that i really connected with
yes please i have a lot of questions
about co-ant so please segue as you like
i'll start out and we'll see where i get
to and now dying to hear your questions
because basically you're not you're on
track a bit with the way you described
them but i can elaborate maybe a little
bit more so
i got lucky i did my first zen retreat
sometime a couple of years i think after
that i've been sitting
diligently daily in my zen and i've done
some weekend retreats and introductions
to zen and stuff by then and then i did
a week-long retreat
led by a korean zen master he himself
was westerner but he'd been it was a
korean lineage and he'd been trained in
he was a
deep guy and he was sort of throwing out
cohen's through the retreat
and actually i was sitting with one of
them was just the basic question who am
i
who am i which is a fundamental cohen
i had a glimpse of what it was pointing
at
i was very lucky i got a glimpse
of how a cohen can work then
it's like this so if you take let's say
you take the most famous kind that
probably i would guess
even
even him probably most people heard
by the way here's the correct wording
you know the sound of two hands clapping
but what is the sound of one hand
that's the formulation
you could say like this you know the
sound of two hands clapping
but do you know the sound of one hand
that's more or less what the cohen is
trying to push us to say
what the hell does this mean you know
the sound of one hand it's a
preposterous question i get people they
try to snap their fingers they want this
is one hand you know no no no no
no so the first thing to say about coins
is they are not riddles to be solved
and our mind wants to make them that it
wants to problem solve them this damn
thing makes no sense i'm going to make
it make sense there must be a way in
which it makes sense
good luck
i might say something like this
there is a way in which they make sense
but your mind will never know it
but part of you will
there's part of us
that the cohen is speaking from and
speaking to
and it's basically
a non-dual
level of experience
non-dual is where
the sense of being separate from the
world has gone
self and world are one
there are
flavors and varieties but fundamentally
it means that the duality
of me being in here
and the world being out there
has gone
so cohen's are actually
emissaries
of
whatever that was that i discovered on
that beach when i was 19 years old and
thousands and millions of people have
discovered what's beautiful about
cohen's is that they know
that that experience is here all the
time
they know it's precious beyond belief
they know that it is
somehow
in some way what we humans
are built to discover
it's a thing that
can transform our life in an utterly
wonderful way
because they show us something about who
we are that we couldn't imagine and it's
it's so crazy we're going around living
our lives the way we do
all predicated on this basic assumption
which is that i am me in here and we
don't really question it we're too busy
living out the dictates that flow from
the assumption that i am what i think i
am in here
it's a to study
this radical thought like well hold on
if i'm going to build my life on this
assumption that there is this me in here
and it wants these things and it doesn't
want those things and my happiness
depends on having
x and not having y
if i'm going to build my life on that
presupposition
shouldn't i at least take a look at the
initial assumption it's really i think
it's equivalent to galileo and
copernicus going from a
geocentric world view where we're
totally convinced the world's flat the
sun moon go around us
to well actually wait a minute maybe not
lo and behold we go around the sun i
think we're in the midst of a
transformation
actually i'm going to be careful when i
say this is really this is going off the
deep end but perhaps
perhaps in this globalized western
culture that where there's so much more
interest in awakening these days than 20
years ago 40 years ago 60 years ago
it was really niche 50 years ago
now as people are hearing about it
there is a reality that we can find
about who we really are and there's a
lot of neuroscience now backing it up
what we think we are is a construction
and actually the way we think the world
is is also a construction that follows
from that you mentioned
ayahuasca earlier we're not going to go
there yet i would like to hear more
about that at some point
but when i think of your experience at
19 on the beach
that distinguishes you from a lot of
people in the sense that you had this
spontaneous
experience of non-duality so you knew it
was a possibility
going into your zen training going into
these various practices
and
i'm wondering if
or how common it is for people to get an
appetizer or a taste of these
non-ordinary states although one i know
that label is not perfect but let's just
for the for the time being call it a
non-ordinary state
is it common that people have that
experience relatively
quickly in their practice because i
could see it being very difficult for
someone who has not had the first hand
experience that you had on the beach or
something like it
to dedicate
years
with the hope that there is some payoff
that they have never tasted or had a
glimpse of and conversely and i'm not
saying that
i recommend psychedelics for all people
i don't i think they are
very powerful tools that have some
applications for some people
but where they do
perhaps represent
an unusual tool in the toolkit is that
with rare exception you are guaranteed
to see an effect
if that makes any sense right that's a
sufficient dose with proper
plant or compound
if you want to induce
the realization
that
you are not
exactly what you believe yourself to be
or at the very least that there are
invisible scripts and stories and
filters that
assemble your current reality
that's a very reliable way to induce
that type of
realization so to summarize is it common
that people get some taste of what you
are describing
relatively
early in their practice or is it
something they have to kind of cross
their fingers and hope for
long
down the road
honestly it's a bit of both and here's a
couple of ways to think about it
one is that yeah if you add a coan into
the mix once somebody's really
committed and settled in their daily
sitting it can be a powerful
stimulant powerful fertilizer
coans are weird they can actually
trigger profound experiences
who knows when they really can so that's
on the one side on the other hand
it's unreliable
and it's certainly not reliable the way
that i think safely administered
plant medicine may be
but here's the thing
two things actually one is that
what zen is teaching us about is
ordinary consciousness right
yeah this is why i i knew that
i knew my
the term non-ordinary consciousness is a
tricky it's a tricky one so please yeah
it's it's not imperfect phrasing but
please continue
i mean the wonder of this is that the
most profound things we can discover
through awakening are here right now
and the process of training with cohen's
is to go like what i experienced on the
beach that was a beginning experience
a far deeper things happened to me
working with cohen's that was a gateway
that got me onto a path it took me a
long time to find the path and a long
time to go down the path but man it was
a beginning the things you can discover
through these cohens that these masters
have discovered and they're sharing with
us through the cohen's hoping
that we'll join them in what they've
discovered it's even more radical and
crazy
but the point is is here right now we're
making discoveries about our ordinary
experience and this is the wondrous
thing about it that you don't have to
have some totally different life again
my master yamada roshi it's not like he
has to reign in his zen mind when he's
in a board meeting
there's no need the boundless
reality
is right there at the board table
able to do everything the board chair
needs to do
that is the wonder so when
whoever this i think was layman pang the
old master said my miracle is that i
chop wood and draw water whatever it was
i
draw water and carry wood i can't
remember that's my miracle he means that
pouring out the kettle for a cup of tea
if we're awake to
the boundless wonder
that's a miracle
it's not like it's a miracle in a way
that
we'll have to sort of swoon and put the
cup down in case we drop it no we just
behave normally we can have a normal
conversation
i don't know if everybody would consider
this a normal conversation because i'm
saying such weird [ __ ] but
but kind of a normal conversation we're
having it i'm you know i'm sitting here
and i know this boundless
infinite
nothing or everything whatever
they're so full of love it's right here
right now it's clear and it doesn't mean
like now i've got to do something so
i've got to switch off
the wonder the boundless love it's not
like that that's where cohen's can take
us
i'm sure way further as well i'm you
know i'm a beginner but
on the other hand what about the people
who they want this they believe in it
and they sit with it and nothing happens
they're sitting with that coin well see
i think personally
what i'm now trying to teach people is
deep in the zen tradition there's a
there's a metaphor it goes way back to
fifth or sixth century china of a cart
track having two ruts
and the idea is that one rut
is
awakened nature itself that's always
here and awaken nature by the way is
everything is one
everything's infinite and everything's
empty those are the three my main things
we can discover about it through
personal experience that's awakened
reality but the other rut is they call
it the four foundations of mindfulness
which comes from early buddhism in india
and the full foundations of mindfulness
are
a gradual path
of learning to be more present
learning to sit with difficulty
learning to sit with our wounds and
pains
and gradually release them and we may
need help with that and you might bring
in therapy you might bring in
pharmaceuticals you might bring in plant
medicine or you might be in all kinds of
stuff to help with that
that's the beginnings of this is the
beginnings of psychological health and
well-being really gradually how practice
can help with that so there's two
ruts for one
track
one rut is awakening and we could put
the coans on that side
the other rut
is the gradual path of sort of healing
and that takes us to deeper and deeper
states of
absorption
we start to get more well-being
with less
it's generally a part of
growth whereby
we can be happier with less and less and
less
until
in deep states of absorption
which is growing out of the mindfulness
we're basically happy with
basically nothing extra we're completely
fulfilled just
sitting and breathing
i've
read you describe awakening as
quote more of a loss than a gain
a marvelous kind of loss end quote
and then there's also a set of
expressions here that maybe you could
explain muichi motzu mujuzol i don't
know if they're long vowels or not in
japanese for the mujuzel i think i can
guess what the first three characters
are but i can't guess what the last two
are
so by more of a loss then again a
marvelous kind of loss what does that
mean
okay so in my book actually i go into
this sort of various experiences
that befell me on the cohen
path one of which was it was basically
it's hard to talk about it it's so
amazing but it's sort of the loss of
everything that somehow seeing
that everything
has been
a dream
and
when we see that everything can actually
fall away
self and world fall away is the way
dogen described it he said body and mind
fall away and
various zen masters have spoken about
this this experience where
everything's just gone
and instead
of it being a horrific
ghastly
void
it's the opposite
because everything is coming from that
emptiness that godness it's generating
everything if we fall away
sufficiently i don't think i've had
the great profound experiences or
anything i've just had experiences that
were profound enough for me
that changed my life and this was the
pivotal one it happened at a certain
point a certain time
during a retreat
everything disappeared
and
i then discovered and henceforth
it hasn't gone away really i can see
everything's being born right now it's
coming out of nothing and that is the
ultimate
wonder
so that's very interesting there was
durability to that there's kind of a
before and after
yes with respect to that experience
that's very interesting and i never
believed that could happen to me i was
such a troubled soul that i'd done all
this practice i'd even had several kind
of you know mind-blowing awakenings and
and still i was a troubled soul i didn't
think i mean i suppose i still have a
bit of a trouble so but i'm a happy one
it's weird i i never thought that i
would be
i could see my teachers these amazing
patient teachers who are guiding me i
can see these these people
they've sort of done it whatever it is
that can be done
they're the kind of person that could do
it
not me no way
and then it just happened this thing
just happened and
it was a fulcrum
in a lifetime and i believe that all of
us can go through this that's why i'm a
teacher because i want to share this
so but here's the thing
i don't think we should sit around in
misery waiting for this kind of thing to
happen so this two rut track idea is
really important to me actually and i've
got this new program called original
love
the zen awakening is often called seeing
original nature and original nature as
well as saying it's
one and it's boundless and it's empty
that's the original nature
what it's like when we find it is it's
like love
it's like love to find that we're part
of everything it's like love to find
that there's nothing
no thing is producing everything
generating everything
infinite generosity that's like love so
in this original love program i got we
got there's awakening is in it but so is
mindfulness so is
support deep kinds of support that we
can open to that are so crucial i've
done a lot of dream work
archetypal kind of work where
figures come and help us and
challenge us and i think that's really
vital for our growth and
and then the third zone in it is sort of
it's got four zones actually like
mindfulness support deep support third
zone is absorption becoming one with
this moment through flow states
absorption states samadhi as they call
it and then the fourth zone is awakening
so it's not like
it's awakening or bust
you know that's a wrong mindset
that shouldn't be the title of this
podcast episode
please
well you can see you've got an awakening
or bust not you know
not like borat could have some sound
bites
spliced in there was a term
that i mentioned that if you can
translate it i would love to hear
what it is just with my fascination with
japan and having lived there for some
time so muichi motsu mu
in what context is that used what does
it mean by the way you got a very nice
accent
thank you thank you yeah
i don't actually speak japanese to my
shame it's not the easiest
it's time consuming
yeah i've been you know quite a number
of times and
spent most of the time staring at the
wall in my master's zendo you know
not the most uh effective way to learn
japanese just like my friend who spent a
lot of time in peru he spent tons of
time in peru doing diatos and working
with ayahuasca and so on and i i asked
him i said you spent nine months in peru
why is your spanish so terrible and he
said i was in the forest trying to talk
to plants the whole time i was like yeah
all right that'll that'll explain it so
yeah you're staring at a wall under the
understanding
into a bucket yeah right
makes it hard to pronounce things
correctly
yeah so so much
one of my teachers reuben abito roshi
is a guy from the philippines
who's also in the same lineage who
teaches
in dallas and he's uh also a professor
at
smu in dallas
he actually used this phrase with me
once when i was in dokusan with going
through cohen's with him you know it
means what is dokkasang
docusan yeah thanks for asking it's a
one-on-one meeting between the zen
student and the zen teacher and actually
that's a when you're working seriously
with the coans if you're getting into
koan training you can work with them in
different ways because they can provide
a really helpful
frame when you're sitting just to have a
cohan in the background it'll change
your sitting but if you're going
seriously through a car and training at
least in our lineage there's a way to do
that with a teacher
so you meet with a teacher and you you
know you work on a cohan and i won't go
into too much detail but anyway we were
meeting
reuben and i that style and at some
point he said yes
which means
not a single thing
an inexhaustible treasury
in other words
what i was trying to describe
this
experience
of everything disappearing
isn't
a horror
quite the reverse
it's an inexhaustible treasury
everything is being
given by
nothing
yeah i don't want to get too absent
because the point it sounds so abstract
until you experience it when you
experience it
it's just it changes your life
irrevocably it can't know yeah there are
certain things that require experience
and words do a very poor job of in
encapsulating or conveying
right it's like if someone's never
orgasmed and you're trying to explain it
to a male and you're like yeah it's kind
of like a sneeze in your balls and he's
like what you know like it's just
you kind of have to be there first and
then the descriptions make sense
is just for people who are curious i'd
actually love help from any native
japanese speakers on the muju
the ichimoku i'm pretty sure is yeah
like
like no heart no mind yeah yeah mu is a
very common character in discussing zen
buddhism ichi is like
one and then mozu is
is
right or kerry it's also it can be used
as a transitive verb but then mood the
same move and then juzo i'm
somebody who's a native speaker let me
know i couldn't find this when i googled
it
maybe muju ju is like maybe the jubung
enough like but mu is the same muju zol
is
like treasury treasure i'm pretty sure
although
some balls then also has the bowl like
the three treasures that's right that's
right so we're taking this down a rabbit
hole yeah
i'm afraid it might be a typo actually
i'm thinking that
oh there
my bad japanese and i bad typing
[Laughter]
no problem uh yeah okay that that would
make that would make more sense i was
like i wonder how
to actually translate that i was trying
to figure that out yeah damn i'm sorry
i'm sorry no no no you're good you're
good
yeah like impermanence
is like everyday conversation would be
like
like ordinary niche day nichijou
would be like everyday conversation
pretty sure it's the same jewel yeah
mujo okay got it so yes okay does that
work yeah yeah roger that i think i
think i got it okay
cool
i was interrupting
to sort of white knuckle this kanji
translation i think you were rescuing me
from going over yet another precipice of
nonsense
that would also be a good good title for
the podcast uh over the precipice of
nonsense that could i kind of i mean i
don't know that sounds like maybe a
great description of koans actually
um well yeah
but but but as long as we know that
you're going to this vast liberation you
know beyond this one that's the thing is
that they're pointing at us that's the
thing that's so hard to get when you
think of one hand sound of one hand what
the hell is that talking about the only
answer is found in us sometimes i've
explained it like this that i don't know
whether you've heard this but there's a
sort of notion in
fiction writing and storytelling that
if you want to know who the main
character of a story is
it's the one who changes
or is the one who has an opportunity to
change and either takes it or doesn't
take it that's the main character so
i've sometimes tried to explain comments
this way
a cohen is a story it doesn't look like
it doesn't sound like it but it is in
fact a story and the main character in
the story is you
so cohen is inviting you
to
change
in a radical way you don't even know
it's asking you to do
and even if you did you wouldn't know
how to do that change
because it's asking us you see the sound
of one hand only becomes
clear
when our self our sense of self drops
away and then suddenly we find it and i
can't explain how or why but i know that
it works and i can sort of tell you that
when it does it's magic
it's marvellous you understand
why this phrase is put that way
you see it
and you see that it's been telling you
something about your very life
that you hadn't been able to see before
and that's why you know i was so
thrilled when i found cohen's because
at last it was actually a system that
knew about what i'd been through on that
beach
and could lead me through beyond it so i
think our round two
will include
a condensed i think master class might
be too ambitious but a detailed
discussion of the system
the systematization of
using koans getting into checking
questions
whether partial realization is possible
or not and so on and so forth so i think
we'll do a very deep double click
on that when we speak again i'd like to
ask you
when you reflect on your experience
or remember your experiences of
let's call it awakening using koans
and this is going to be another one of
my
notoriously convoluted compound
questions but
how similar or dissimilar are those
experiences from say your experience on
ayahuasca because it is possible with a
tool like ayahuasca to arrive at places
where you feel
liberated from
the
constraints the tight shoes of the
rational mind you absolutely can arrive
in those places including
feeling at times the sort of beauty and
infinite potential of
the emptiness that you can access
the two questions are
how similar or dissimilar how would you
describe the similarities of differences
and then why did you decide to
consume ayahuasca
and you can tackle those in either
direction
maybe i'll take the second first
consistent with this sort of philosophy
of the two rats that's that even though
we may have had awakening me even we've
become
even perhaps somewhat consistently
access that awakening world we can do it
nevertheless we're still a fallible
vulnerable
ailing aging mortal
suffering human being what awakening
shows us is that the suffering human
being is themselves
part of the infinite wonder but
nevertheless you still got the suffering
being the needs tending so
i was i know this was long ago actually
i was
i guess i was in my mid-30s i was in my
zen training
i was very unhappy i'd been
working on a book a novel actually funny
enough said in peru that
was sort of revisiting you know that my
early trip when i was 19 and i'd written
i thought a really promising start to it
and then i got totally stuck
and i just couldn't figure out how to
keep going i was real you know severe
writer's block and i was quite depressed
i was teaching down at a college in the
south of new mexico and it was really
not not happy
for various reasons and
i was going out to breakfast with a
couple of friends one morning
and i just ordered huevos rancheros and
this friend of mine called me who lived
in santa fe and basically said henry
you gotta come and do this thing this
evening i did this trip with this
peruvian shaman like a couple of days
ago ayahuasca i became a panther it's
the most amazing thing you gotta come
and do it but you gotta fast and he's
doing another one tonight and i was
literally sort of my wave off
arrived and i was cutting the first bite
out
hearing his voice on the phone
and
this feeling came on i don't know if
you're familiar with like oh [ __ ] i
gotta do this i know i gotta do this i
wanna eat these eggs but actually i want
to do this thing more it's more
important even though i don't really
want to do it
that night
that evening that night
so i did not eat my eggs
[Laughter]
and and i went up in a state of you know
the there's depressive sort of dragging
himself up and i went to the studio
where it was held it was a proven shaman
and
drink the vile tea
the weirdness comes on and i had a
hellish time basically hell punctuated
by
moments of extraordinary peace
i shot up into this upper atmosphere and
realized i was an asteroid i you know i
had a weird [ __ ] happened you know it
was
and i vomited a ton and it was scary and
it was
overwhelming and
when it was kind of over i thought
well thank god that's over i'm never
doing that again but actually the next
day
i felt like i was sort of
a teenager again it felt like a whole
layer of swaddling of
something some kind of being taken away
from me and i was alive in a
in a younger fresher way it was it was
marvelous and the book i'd been
working on just kind of
in my mind it was like looking at a map
that opened out in front of me that sort
of unfolded in front of me the whole
map of the book was right there and i
carried on working on it and it actually
ended up happening and doing rather well
that book and
that was my first taste of ayahuasca
later
after
years of zen training and really being
in a very different place
i just had this friend who was a
trained in in the peruvian style and i
was just curious to try it again and i
did three
ayahuasca ceremonies like on
once a month for three months
and it was totally different i i didn't
have a very
powerful time and but it was kind of
nice but i i really just basically i
didn't need it to the same extent i had
done before i didn't have a lot to purge
i was
quite mellow i i actually helped
because i was in a totally different
state how did you help you were rinsing
renting out buckets holding people's
ponytails what was in what fashion
a little bit of that but actually also i
sort of at a certain point in that
tradition they talked about
grandmother you know the plant is
grandmother and you've got to let
grandmother come in and do the work she
needs to do
so
i was doing that in all those three
times i was just totally surrendered and
grandmother didn't seem to have a whole
lot to do
this wish came up i said to grandmother
if anybody else needs to purge let them
push through me
and i know it's just some crazy idea
that came up in the midst of the trip
but
i had a feeling that there was one
person there who did sort of
i don't know why i'm even bringing this
up it was just i'm just trying to say i
was in a totally different space when i
did it yeah and so so okay so now but
going to the the more important matter
you're bringing no no no no no no no i'm
not gonna let that go so easily so
so you did end up purging then in this
case
actually i think i did once for what i
felt was somebody else
for what it's worth that
experience
and to be clear i'm not claiming that
this can be proven i'm not claiming that
mechanism is understood if it is real
i'm not saying it isn't just a
fabrication of the mind but the
subjective experience of purging for
someone else or having someone else
purge for you is quite common
is that right
yes
it's so it's not it's not surprising to
me to hear that
oh wow that's that's nice to have that
affirmed actually yeah for what that's
worth
but look now to the matter of
deep kinds of
regular regularly scheduled programming
like like awakening on ayahuasca
normal programming right yeah so here's
my take on it which of course is based
on my experience
i have known i mean a number of zen
students i've known
who have used plant medicine and found
it profoundly helpful
here and there they've reported to me
an experience within
a plant ceremony
that sounds like
a zen awakening what i was saying
seeing the original nature
i don't think that that's commonly what
people experience
in the way zen defines it
all the way through
a psychedelic experience i i really
don't believe that
but i think there are moments within a
psychedelic experience for some people
sometimes that are like that
now but here's the thing though is how
i'm just now thinking one
student has really a strong
experience of you know it's called the
japanese's ken show
for seeing original nature had a really
quite a strong one actually using
another form of dmt
but
there's something about
having it
with a completely clear ordinary mind
versus having it
when you know there's
a powerful
psychotropic
compound in your bloodstream
that will wear off
there's something about it that
is just
i've seen that the impact is different
i'm not saying i know that it always
would be
but that when somebody is stone cold
sober and this happens
it's so undeniable that you've really
seen something real
and it's not induced by anything
i'm convinced that you know this moment
right now
has sort of different levels to it
different levels of experience right
here and now
and in these moments of awakening that's
what we're dropping into
and they can go all the way down to
nothing
and the love that's there
it's right here now but if you're
i mean i would i'd like to hear your
take on this yeah i think you've
probably had a lot more psychedelic
experience than i have i'm sure
i'm really so thrilled that psychedelic
research is in full swing again i think
it's
absolutely i mean i see it from my
perspective i see it
mostly as an incredible mental health
tool and i'm sure that's an insufficient
way to look at it but at least from that
side i can see
my god this is going to be fantastic in
coming years and decades
helping people with depression anxiety
fear of death
love of death you know how amazing to be
able to have love of death that's what
awakening can do
deep love of life deep love of death i
mean that doesn't mean long enough for
death you know it means just
you know somehow really happy that it's
part of the whole picture i can't
explain why but we can be there's so
much we could explore here i think
that psychedelics properly administered
properly and respectfully used with
certain guide rails and guidelines
can be really helpful
for certain conditions in certain people
and i think they're
useful
for
exploring facets of
the mind itself and and reality yeah we
could put that in quotation marks since
i think that reality as we experience it
is largely a constructed
hallucination to begin with which there
are many ways to kind of explore this
there's a book called biocentrism that
does a decent job of introducing thought
exercises although i disagree with some
of the things in the book it's an
interesting read
what i would love to see and maybe it
already exists but would be to see
for instance and this is it would be
very hard to do this non-invasively but
if it were possible to compare
the
neurochemical
activity
of someone again like who's going to pay
for this research and how on earth would
you even
structure
a study is kind of a fool's errand
probably but
let's just say hypothetically that you
could compare someone
having the experience of kensho
or an awakening
with someone
90 minutes after drinking ayahuasca who
would subjectively report right the
phenomenology
of the experience would include
something akin to kensho or awakening
it'd be so fascinating to compare those
two
because
whether
let's just say catalyzed by
a cup of tea
or catalyzed by diligent training
as dennis mckenna would say our who's an
ethnopharmacologist
our experience of reality is mediated
through neurotransmitters
by and large right so
so you can change your experience of
consciousness let's just say using
holotropic breath work is one example
ultimately that would
catalyze and induce certain
electrochemical changes that would
then help confer a certain
experience and i'd love to see
it would be fascinating i'd love to see
i think it's too optimistic but it'd be
so endlessly fascinating to see
how the sort of presentation of these
experiences differ along those
parameters
i also think that the container and the
cultural context and the assistance with
constructing
meaning out of
unusual experiences
is so important that
it is difficult to i would imagine get
to a point where you experience in your
practice can show without a lot of
deliberate
practice
at least as something that is repeatable
but you could you know find a rent a
shaman on craigslist and show up as like
number 17 in someone's basement and have
you know
some lady who's watched too many
lord of the rings movies like smack you
on the head with a feather and give you
a super big gulp of ayahuasca and like
you're going to have a very intense
unusual experience but then what to do
with it and i think it can be very
i know it can be extremely destabilizing
for people and to that extent i think
the downside risk seems to be much lower
when you are practicing within
the
tradition
of in this case zen buddhism
and there's a lot to be said for that
capping of downside on some level
well yeah
you've got a whole lot of support you've
got a profound level of support but i'm
wary of equating
the whole of psychedelic experience with
kensho i really am no no i think they're
very different i'm not trying to equate
the two i think that
if i'm just saying if someone were to
i've never experienced kensho in the zen
buddhist sense there's no way for me to
know
there's no way for me to confirm that
and you know a lot of very strange
things
happen in psychedelic experiences that
probably have nothing to do with what
what you would
conceptualize or think of as as kensho i
certainly think they're very different
things
but they may be kind of edging at
aspects
of
similar spaces i think yeah yes i agree
with that i agree with that and man what
a healing space it is right
it can be
yeah i mean it can be i think it can be
with insufficient support with the wrong
preparation at least in the case of
psychedelics it can be incredibly
destabilizing and
i mean people do end up
in uh
very bad circumstances if they have
ayahuasca in particular i think is a
dicey
proposition for a lot of people i mean
you just don't know when you're gonna
pull a joker card and
it's always in the deck whereas with the
practices that you're describing perhaps
it's a little
it's less likely although although i
would have to imagine i mean it
certainly it happens at vipassana
retreats and other places where
there are people who have
really difficult kind of breakdown
experiences have you seen that happen in
the
zen buddhist practices also
i've only seen it once and actually it
wasn't a big deal we just helped him put
him in a cage kept him fed
he was fine a few weeks later
he was fine that 48 hours later he was
you know
and you know took him off the cushion
you know actually yeah but but i want to
say one other thing which is that
it's to do with this ordinariness that
somehow in zen
it's not quite right to sort of sit
because i want to have a kensho
experience there's something about
sitting itself and just
being
more and more
embedded in this moment
so that it becomes more and more
fulfilling and okay
just as it is that is perhaps the
greatest reward that we are learning
to
come home to ourselves to come to terms
with ourselves
to just be ourselves
not needing anything not even cancer
that's part of the training as well
that this practice isn't just
for me to get something i want namely a
marvelous experience
there's something else going on as well
also likewise that
a master like yamada roshi and you know
we're all aspiring to that all of us are
in training to be
able to live
what can we call it a fully awakened
life
the heart is fully open
there's great freedom there's great
flexibility of sort of register i can
see through this moment i can see it's
transparent i can see that it's concrete
as well i can
see that i'm getting a little tired i
can see that there's infinite joy i can
see that there's infinite love
all this it can be present
in an ordinary moment and of utter
sobriety there's something
about its impact on our ordinary life
that somehow is just such a treasure
and you know and so
it's not just about special experience
it's
am i making any sense here
you are making sense so so ken can show
robust is not the the title of your your
forthcoming
how-to book
in fact my new book is called original
love i mean for real
nice nice that was good
that was good so now is it a book is it
a program is it both it seems to be both
why why do either or when you can do
both end well right it's a manuscript at
this point which i think i hope is
getting nearly finished it's been a
marvelous journey writing it but it's a
program and a course as well and
i'm actually just so excited about it
it's thrilling to be able to teach this
full spectrum of what meditation can be
because i think there's confusion what's
awakening what's mindfulness how do they
and if i'm awakened or if i've had an
awakening experience am i awakened why
am i still so miserable why do i get
anxious still
actually we're multi-dimensional and to
have got this way of addressing these
different
zones and being clear about it so it's
kind of a map it's a all parts are
suffused with love that's my main point
that in any level of any zone of
practice
love is usually
the thing somehow or other that
triggers the transformation that opens
up things
yeah where can people learn more about
original love or find the program
yeah well at mountingcloud.org
at
henryshuckman.com both of those
anybody who read my existing book would
learn a lot actually about many of the
things
we've been discussing one blade of grass
one blade of grass subtitle finding the
old road of the heart a zen memoir which
i have on my bookshelf
in austin courtesy of of our mutual
friend kevin rose in fact
and i recommend i definitely recommend
people check it out your stories are
insane i mean you have
and i mean that in a sort of yankee
compliment
kind of way keeping in mind it's the
same person who thought old-fashioned
[ __ ] was something much more sensual
but
one blade of grass i definitely
recommend people check out one blade of
grass and also
the
program and your website just to go to
the website go to mountaincloud.org go
to henryshuckman.com and you will see an
assortment of different resources and
that's i suppose a good repository kind
of a home base for a lot of things that
we're
discussing
henry i think
we
should do around two at some point if
you're still open to it you can sleep on
it and decide if you're willing to put
up with this type of
stochastic
memento non-linear conversation a second
time but
if you can put up with me again i'd be
thrilled to you know
wonderful well i mean we've covered a
good amount of ground the great news is
i don't have to do really any
prep for the second conversation because
i have 70 of my notes still remaining in
front of me untouched
and is there anything else you'd like to
share like to
add as closing comments requests you'd
like to make of people listening
suggestion anything at all that you'd
like to add before we
wrap up for round one i'd like to just
acknowledge my deep gratitude to my
teachers and to say
it can be tricky
having a spiritual teacher a spiritual
guide is fraught with difficulty i was
very distrustful
for a long time myself found it very
hard to accept a teacher until i finally
found
somebody i could accept but it is
wonderful if you find people who are
really committed to helping others in
their practice
but have no power trip of their own they
just want to share the teaching they've
received
for those who want to partake of it you
know there are people like that there's
shark infested waters for sure
spirituality
so be careful
but you can find safe
deep teachers i'm not putting myself
forward by the way i'm a shallow you
know i i think i'm reasonably god i
might i think i'm safe but i'm not deep
enough i'm working on it but you can
find people who are
and
it's a great gift if you do
so that's one thing i just want to say
and actually i want to say huge thanks
to you tim
you took a chance on having this crazy
british zen whatever fool
and it's very nice of you
my pleasure i mean kevin was putting his
his nuts on the table so i i took it
very seriously i was like well look it's
it's
it's very it's on record as kevin's
recommendation in our last recording of
the random show and i have great faith
in kevin and he's a huge fan of yours
and has learned an incredible
amount from you and has taken a lot from
the practice over the last year and i've
i've had front row seats to
seeing it so for people who
wonder what the experience might
transmit to one's sort of waking reality
outside of your personal experience that
you've shared i've seen it in kevin and
it's been
very noticeable from the outside looking
in and he's certainly
been very excited for us to have a
conversation and vis-a-vis his
excitement i have been
eager to have this conversation and i
i've really enjoyed getting to know you
a bit and this will be
part one
of at least two so we'll figure out the
scheduling at some point soon
i also need to get to new mexico i've
been meaning to spend more time in new
mexico to to visit there are a number of
different places i'd love to explore
god i'd love to show you around to
whatever extent you want to be you know
yeah yeah it's like you've got zen
buddhism you've got meow wolf you've got
yeah yeah
skiing you have all sorts of things yes
yes in in new mexico can i just i just
while we're on the subject of kevin i
just want to say what a marvelous man he
is incredibly generous incredibly
curious
and so supportive in so many ways
just a treasure of a guy and i'm very
very very happy that i've got to know
him
and he's very serious and he's so
serious about his zen he really gets it
that
it's got great possibilities and you've
got yeah you know actually that's a you
know it's a great point because some
native japanese speaker can correct this
but there's an expression i think it's
hiya
which means
it or he
heats up quickly and cools off quickly
and
what that means is that kevin's life is
a vast collection of
two-week passions
and he is expert in a number of areas
but he gets very very very excited about
something and then two weeks later i'm
like oh how's x going he's like i am
over that i'm not doing that anymore so
it is all the more remarkable that he is
stuck with zen practice under your
guidance
for as long as he has with the diligence
with which he's treated it's a very
clear
kevin don't kill me but it's it seems to
me to be a very potent anomaly
and that really speaks volumes so
i'm really happy that he's engaged in
the practice also
so henry thank you for taking the time
once again this has been great and i'm
actually really happy that we covered
what we covered and that there's so much
left to cover because
why do i do these conversations other
than to explore i
get a lot out of them myself people can
find you at henry shukman that's
s-h-u-k-m-a-n henry shookman.com
mountaincloud.org i'm sure they can find
the social and so on on those websites
your memoir is one blade of grass i
highly recommend people check it out
they can also find
the original love program and more info
on the websites that i mentioned we'll
link to everything
in the show notes at tim dot blog slash
podcast so if you just search zen on
that page this episode will pop right up
and
what fun thank you again for for taking
the time oh man much gratitude to you
and yeah i feel the connection i was
hoping
i sort of feel it it's yeah
very nice
yeah yeah yeah you're uh
you're serious without taking yourself
too seriously which is nice
and i really enjoy
this new terrain i've been interested in
zen for a very long time i've known i've
had very close mentors and friends in
japan who were dedicated zen
practitioners
but it's really something i have very
very little familiarity with so i'm
looking forward to digging deeper
really getting into the nitty-gritty
details of
koan use and
also the
hierarchy and progression within
the
zen practice and zen communities and
many many more questions but we'll get
to that in round two so thank you henry
and uh many thanks to
everybody listening so until next time
thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that i've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read and that i've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to
4hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason the app and
its simple 4 rule method will change the
way you think about your money and help
you gain total control so you can plan
for the things you need and get the
things you want without guilt or stress
to give you an idea on the cult favorite
side to date they know of at least seven
customers who have customized their
license plates to mark the occasion of
purchasing a new car in cash
and these fans do this by including ynab
you need a budget on their license
plates so people love this app you need
a budget has helped millions of people
transform their finances save their
marriages and live life on their own
terms i even asked pete adney who's been
on the podcast best known as mr money
mustache super popular episode what he
thought and he's a big fan of the
founder and what they're doing uni the
budget's simple four rule method will
actually teach you how to manage your
money you will learn a new way of
thinking new habits and new behaviors
that will help you get out of debt break
the paycheck to paycheck cycle and build
wealth faster the you need a budget team
is committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet if you want to learn they can
teach you on average new budgeters save
more than six hundred dollars by month
two and six thousand dollars in their
first year so try the app free for 34
days no credit card required at you need
a budget dot com tim spelled as you
would expect in proper english try you
need a budget free for 34 days no credit
card required at you need a budget dot
com slash tim and just to explain 34
days that's because most people
reconcile at the end of the month or 38
periods so having a couple of days of
cushion helps folks out so 34 days with
no credit card required at you need a
budget dot slash
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e i have had so much
tea in my life i've been to china i've
lived in china in japan i've done tea
tours i drink a lot of tea and 10 years
plus of physical experimentation and
tracking has shown me many things cheap
among them that gut health is critical
to just about everything and you'll see
where tea is going to tie into this it
affects immune function weight
management mental performance emotional
health you name it i've been drinking
fermented poo air tea specifically
pretty much every day for years now
huirti delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome the
problem
with good poo air is that it's hard to
source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why peaks fermented
poo puyer tea crystals have become my
daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them through my friends dr peter
tia and kevin rose peak crystals are
cold extracted using only wild harvested
leaves from 250 year old tea trees i
often kick start my mornings with their
poor green tea their poor black tea and
i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the black specifically
is amazing it's very very it's like a
delicious barnyard
very peaty if you like whiskey and stuff
like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic molds contaminants commonly found
in tea there's also zero prep or brewing
required as the crystals dissolve in
seconds so you can just drop it into
your hot tea or i also make iced tea and
that saves a ton of time and hassle
so peek is offering 15 off their
priorities for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer simply visit peaktee.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available to listeners at this
podcast that's
t dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url you also have a 30 day
satisfaction guarantee so your purchase
is risk free one more time check it out
peak t that's p i q u e t e a dot com
slash tip
[Applause]